got a whole bunch of nonsense to talk
about today we're going to stay away
from a lot of the really really crazy
stuff and we're just going to talk about
the crazy stuff no i want to talk about
the cdc
listen man what they're they're changing
the rules all right
here we go
let's just have a conversation ready all
of a sudden the rules are changing you
have to sit in their room for 14 days
now it's five why nobody knows all of a
sudden they're saying hey that pcr test
uh it doesn't know the difference
between influenza or covid i don't even
know what that means okay and then to
make matters even worse they said oh
yeah by the way once you go into
isolation after you tested positive
don't worry about taking the pcr test at
the end because it can be positive for
up to 12 weeks what is going on
nobody knows but you're stupid i'm
stupid they're stupid and they're stupid
that's what those people think because
literally this is just a moving target
our entire society is literally being
held hostage by people who don't know
what they're doing wake up people the
newly updated cdc guidelines don't
require testing at the end of isolation
they're literally saying if you sat in
isolation because you tested positive
and then you waited to get a negative
test you're an idiot you didn't have to
do that
if you sat in your room for 14 days
you're an idiot you didn't have to do
that it's only five days
what is going on people what is going on
i don't know i'm not a scientist i don't
claim to know any of this [ __ ] all i
know is that if you tell me some rules
and our entire society rotates and tries
to follow them and then every week or
every day i mean literally it's every
day things change the rules change the
rules change the rules change the rules
it's like yo you know what i'm gonna do
this is what i'm gonna do fellas i'm
gonna just sit back
y'all let me know when you figure it out
uh what do you want me to do i can't i
can't figure out what the cdc is gonna
do it's like whoever runs the cdc
whatever guy girl [ __ ] or genius runs
the cdc they wake up every day
uh i think today we're gonna have people
sit in their houses for six days
tomorrow
i think we're gonna have people sit in
their houses for 10 days
what voice is that
i think that we're gonna have oh carson
wentz he got kovit i need him to play
this weekend for my wager we're gonna
have it five days now
like you know what
like what is going on here if you look
up omicron in the dictionary a synonym
is is the cold
i mean i'm just i'm just saying is that
true no it's a joke
but i've heard like i i've i've heard
some friends that got omicron and it is
much much much less severe so honestly
it's probably a good thing because it's
natural it's a natural vaccination for a
lot of people adam farrell in the
comments said the cdc policies are
transitory
no but it's true it's it's uh
frustrating because like look you can
believe that vaccinations are good
they're helpful they protect a lot of
people all these things but also still
believe that people should keep their
freedoms right and the ability to choose
on these things and i think what has
happened is a lot of politicians over
the last two years like literally we're
two years into this now a lot of
politicians have taken away basic
societal social and economic freedoms
from people under the guise of public
health and safety when really all
they've done done is abuse their power
that's literally all that's happening
spitting fired
that's really what's happening i want to
be super clear right there's nobody up
here who thinks we understand this stuff
nobody up here thinks that all we're
saying that they don't understand it
either right that's the whole key to
this thing is that eventually people
just start to say to themselves yo
it's like everything else in life you
meet your heroes you meet the people who
are supposed to be in charge and you
rise they're figuring out as they go as
well these people got no clue they were
literally telling us one thing when they
switch then it's this then it's this
then it's like yo they have no clue and
by the way i would actually trust them
more if they just came out and said yo
we got no clue but we're gonna figure it
out i'd like you know what thank you
thank you finally someone's being honest
because guess what the difference
between 14 days and five days is a hell
of a lot of days yo like wait what like
how did that happen and oh by the way
now by the way the test doesn't even
work
the thing that we've been literally
telling everyone to go do it does not
work like what kind of reasoning is that
it literally makes no sense and they're
not even going to be literally people
are just going along with it people are
parading around virtue signaling other
people to go do these things that
literally do not make any sense yeah i
mean look at this point like we've held
our tongue for a long time because again
we don't know we i don't know what the
answer is right and like i want people
to be safe i want our society to be able
to function and people not be scared to
go outside but also if they're gonna get
sick if they go outside then maybe we
should actually have people not go
outside all this stuff i don't know what
the answer is but i also know now it is
very very very clear they don't know
[ __ ] either and that's when people start
to say wait a minute why are we
listening to people who have no clue
they don't know anything and so when you
start to think about that again this is
why there's an erosion of trust in the
institutions it's because they're not
being honest just come out and say we
don't know
how is it that literally the entire
world was going to shut down because
somebody took a test and that test meant
that you were going to die and now all
of a sudden they're coming down and say
oh yeah by the way the test can be
positive for 12 weeks but like you can
go outside that was a week ago
what changed what test show me the test
they ran that changed their mind
literally this is literally what they're
doing
i think that you should sit in your
house for five days like they have no
clue they're literally making [ __ ] up by
the way what they really should be doing
and i think one of the craziest things
that isn't being talked about is if you
really want to mandate stuff how about
you start telling people yo go work out
and eat healthy
that'll be a wild idea yeah i mean
there's plenty of data like
just go look up the data relative to the
health of an individual that gets
covered versus the non-health of an
individual so there's plenty of things
that can be done but ultimately i think
literally it's just time to move on
right like it's time to move on with not
only life but the show yeah
listen all i'm saying is that
nobody knows what's going on
including
the average person and the people inside
of the organizations and that's okay
like guess what it's science there's a
bunch of [ __ ] we still don't know
there's lights in the sky nobody knows
where the hell they come from we're
trying to figure it out right there's a
bunch of things that we're still testing
that come out of the earth we don't know
what's going on that's okay
but let's just call it what it is we
don't know we're trying to figure it out
rather than pretend like there's
somebody who comes down off a mountain
with uh literally the commandments and
it's like hey by the way here's the
rules live your life by these rules the
only thing i'll say on it is if you're
feeling sick i hope you get better and
if you're healthy be grateful for your
health